past pandemics have shaped urban
environments how we know them today
yellow fever led to the boulevards of
paris and public parks
cholera created london sewer systems and
coveted 19 is certainly not the first
real health crisis new york city has
been through from yellow fever
to tuberculosis to the 1918 flu
the headlines may read the same but with
each wave of contagious illness
they have helped shape the city scene
today tom hansen takes us to the lower
east side of manhattan
people are really giving so much thought
as to how we can
how we can rethink every space you know
from parks to offices to our houses to
the cities as a whole
where many people see our urban areas
struggling architectural digest editor
samuel cochran
sees possibility you know i think it's
an exciting time for architects and
designers
no idea is off the table cochrane
believes the next chapter in public
health and urban areas
is here he told us all you have to do is
look to the past
so this street tells a story about
public health in new york city
i think that's right david favaloro runs
the new york city tenement museum
founded in 1988 after it had been
shuttered for more than half a century
how interconnected are urban planning
and infectious disease
i would go so far as to say one of the
core
threads that underlies the way we've
thought about city building
really from the late 18th century to the
present has been in the interest
of improving the city's resiliency in
the face of
public health crises your museum
actually provides a snapshot
of new york city public health in a way
yeah these buildings have seen
everything from yellow fever
to cholera to tuberculosis to polio
we're in the second floor hall here the
walls of the tenement museum date as far
back as 1863
when new yorkers lived and worked in
tight spaces
it was not uncommon to operate a garment
factory
making clothing manufacturing clothing
out of your home making a living
in the living room making a living in
the living room they believed
that germs like tuberculosis other
airborne diseases actually attach itself
to a dress like this
and a toxic combination of poor air
ventilation no running water and no
proper plumbing
made these tenement apartments a vector
for infectious disease
to spread this was the bathroom this was
the bathroom for the entire building
22 apartments 22 households 80 or so
people using four outdoor toilets with
contagious diseases tearing through
parts of the u.s
housing regulations changed their
building codes to include
access to open air this is the
building 103 orchard street when this
was a residence
this air shaft would have provided light
and air into the interior rooms of the
apartments below us and that would have
been all the more important
with airborne diseases right uh the
light part being the idea that sunlight
often can kill bacteria or viruses
tuberculosis or or something like
covalent nitin all right so here we're
in the kitchen
there were also changes made to the
interiors of buildings
with the 1901 tenement house act which
required windows between
rooms so this would not have been an
original
part of the house that's correct it
seems like when it comes to urban
planning we always
are reactive i think yeah i think that's
absolutely the case and that has always
been the case
it's an interesting i think conundrum
how do you be strategic
and proactive about public health about
something that's unknown
you know in some cases and in the era of
covet 19
that's a question architects like joe
yacobellas are attempting to answer yet
again
his firm mojo stoomer associates
designed the interior of this major
development in long island city
just before the pandemic they're at a
very unique point in that they're having
to respond to covet having already
finished most of their construction
finding ways to redesign around
the the new realities of kovid
they're going to be one of the first to
market to really see how people respond
the team and other architects around the
world are responding with modern
technology
there are advances in uv light
technology that can
help to kill or eliminate the growth of
germs and bacteria on surfaces
there will be advances in air filtration
technologies and the number of air
changes per
hour in public spaces antimicrobial
surfaces
things like touchless faucets and face
sensors and voice activation
all of those things are going to help us
navigate a post-covert world and be self
safer and be healthier cochrane says
using lessons of the past is important
to catapult design and architecture
into the future there's going to be a
lot of i think renewed attention
and care taken to rethinking these
spaces and i think
there'll be a lot of good will towards
investing in those spaces for the good
of society
so yes going forward i think i certainly
certainly the built environment
as a remedy for health concerns is a
profound opportunity
for cbs this morning saturday tom hansen
new york
fascinating we've said this before but
think about how different our lives are
going to look for the next 20 30 40
years based on just what's happened in
the past eight months
right and whether or not it's in
battling a pandemic or just a flu right
obviously so many of these things can
make a difference yeah it's amazing what
tragedy uh sort of lifts up and lifts
out for the future
when it comes to our buildings and our
cities and how they're planned